this serious even I'm going back to
school learning new skills honing my
techniques and taking on the very best
of the food industry today I'm going to
turn my hand to the ancient art of
noodle pulling phalanx a chef at one of
the handful of restaurants in Britain
that still pull their own fresh noodles
good morning good morning hey how are
you I'm fine thank you for 4,000 years
tradition has dictated that noodles must
be pulled into a continuous unbroken
string and that a minimum of six paws is
needed to get them to the right
thickness what's the secret of pulling a
good noodle does it have a certain taste
a hand porn order has got more
elasticity when to eat it you can taste
the difference and it's fresh it's the
most important it's different from the
mass production yeah you have to be very
faint yes you have to be very free
because it's very tough yeah do it all
day long yeah how long would it take me
to go to that speed soon yeah ten years
ten years I've got one afternoon to
learn from fate before we go into a
head-to-head challenge in this age old
food skill here we go Wow lots of flour
yeah that's right yeah yep
oh yeah unda you're gonna do six times
six times that's right and you Thompson
together you will come up to 164 strains
of new jobs that's how you do it and put
it into the boiling water
Jesus sorry yeah pull it even late yeah
yeah the first rash down okay yep okay
they go round yes that's right
and then pull it again stretching it oh
no no he's a disaster
no [ __ ] oh no no uh-huh
don't you touch me right hey you say
you're stupid why a mind breaking when
he gets to the fifth pool I come back
round for the sixth why is that you have
to let you come back to Lhasa City so
when you pull it you have to bring it
back this is a lot harder than I
expected to be but here we go again
no don't snap why hey wipe ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] so you
Center that's right I'm pulling it along
Raji Raji
sheesh it's so frustrating because the
techniques in feeling the dough pulling
it retracting and you make look so easy
amazing last one now come on I'm talking
about you do you're right you're do you
right yeah pull it back yes
oh that's right come on baby one more
time yes with each attempt I'm getting
better but I'm nowhere near as good as
Fay I'm gonna have to work hard to be
with a chance against him as we go head
to head to set a new world record in
noodle pulling go back home and practice
walk go back home practice yeah thank
you for the encouragement